[Music]
lina is with us in tucson arizona hi
lina how are you
i'm jeremiah are you better than i
deserve what's up
i am a little bit at odds with my
husband my husband has been bit by the
solar bug
the solar boat i know that was a bug
are those loose in arizona
and sometimes
uh no he is determined to get us to get
solar and i disagree as it would result
in a loan because we don't have the
finances to do it outright
and your question is what
how do i convince them it's a bad
idea why do you think it's a bad idea
it bothers me the whole idea of having a
loan just creates more financial
pressure and i feel like stressed and
i'm the one that does all the books
yeah
so um
it is i i believe in solar panels i
endorse solar panel companies in several
of our 600 markets that this show airs
in
and i am not against solar at all
as a matter of fact the solar technology
is greatly advanced over what it was uh
10 or 15 years ago
and so the quality of it it's like
batteries in these battery operated cars
you know the whole thing's different
than it was a few years ago the
batteries wouldn't last 10 minutes now
they're last you know for 300 miles same
thing's true in solar the efficiency has
gone way up
so they're excellent products
there is not an excellent product on the
planet that i will tell you to buy with
debt
bad idea
well wait a minute it pays for itself
yeah over five years during which time
the solar panels become worth zero they
do not add value to your home there's no
market study that shows they add value
to the home equal to their cost
so the only way you make your money back
is on savings on utilities and if you've
got a five year or less break even
period that's a pretty sweet break even
period on solar
and the only way you invest in something
with a five year break-even period is
with cash
yeah his biggest argument is that we'd
be changing our 400 electric bill for a
150
loan
no that's not true is the problem
because the value of the stinking things
is going down you sell the house the
loan is screwing up your house sale
you've got a mess on your hands he's
only thinking about this month he's not
looking at the overall picture it's a
very bad analysis that leads people to
finance solar panels
don't don't do it i i agree with you i
wouldn't do it
anything you want to add or no i mean
that the biggest thing here is i i don't
know how much debt you guys have lena
but i want you guys to realize that debt
freedom is just a lifestyle that you're
going to live and that means we're gonna
figure out a way to pay for this thing
in cash now i mean a sinking fund for
six months that we put this money
towards in order to pay for that in cash
that's the only way i want you to get
these solar panels